this is a critical issue with regards to
the shamanic transformation is that
people go through these terrible
terrible experiences often drug induced
by the way with regards to the shaman
they usually use psychedelic chemicals
of one form another often mushrooms but
but they've come up with some very
strange concoctions like ayahuasca down
in the Amazon and ayahuasca is an
amazing substance it's made out of the
bark of one thing and another plant
whose name I don't remember that hardly
even grow in the same place and that has
to be cooked together in a special way
and no one has any idea how the damn
Amazonians figured that out it looks
impossible and if you ask them they say
well the plants told us how to do it
which you know Western people don't find
very helpful but the shamans are
perfectly helped happy with that that
description in ayahuasca takes them
apart and it does that in part because
it's affects the serotonergic system
very very powerfully like all
psychedelics do and it transports them
to another world and that's how they
interpret it and and and and what we
know about psychedelics you could put in
a thimble and then throw the thimble
away we know nothing about psychedelics
there's new experiments going on at
Johns Hopkins for example with
psilocybin which is part of this active
chemical in magic mushrooms same
structure basically as LSD and mescaline
and all the real psychedelics have
basically the same structure except the
one that's derived from Amanita muscaria
which is called muscarinic acid and it's
a it's its own weird thing that no one
knows anything about anyways they have
profound neuro chemical effects in very
small doses and the research group at
Johns Hopkins has given psilocybin to
research subjects you know purified
psilocybin because they started the new
experimentation with psychedelics and
that's been banned for like 40 years
because psychedelics were so terrifying
to our culture that we just put them
away it's like oh no we're not going
there and so even from a research
perspective and even though some of the
psychedelics look very promising for the
treatment of disorders like alcoholism
they recently used psilocybin to help
people stop smoking down at Johns
Hopkins and I think they had an 80%
success rate which is just like that's
just absolutely mind-boggling
and so but if you give people psilocybin
and they haven't
mystical experience which is very common
among people who take these sorts of
chemicals then their personality
transforms permanently such that one
year later their one standard deviation
higher in openness and openness is the
creativity dimension and that seems to
be a permanent transformation so that's
really remarkable and about 80% of the
people who undergo the Johns Hopkins
experiments report that the experience
is like one of the two or three most
important things they've ever that's
never ever happened to them and so well
that's that's something you know it's
like and then there's this guy named
Rick Strassman down at I think he was at
the University of Texas and he did
experimentation with DMT and DMT
dimethyltryptamine I remember I remember
correctly is the active ingredient in
ayahuasca and you produce it in your
brain and it's in plants it's like a
very common chemical but DMT is a weird
hallucinogen because it has an
extraordinarily short mechanism of
action it's like and people who take it
report that they're blasted out of their
body like out of a cannon and then they
go out somewhere and encounter beings of
various sorts and then ten minutes later
they're back and virtually everyone
reports that which is really strange and
so strassman was giving people DMT
intravenously so that the trip would
last longer he this was all all you know
NIH funded experimentation all cleared
with the relevant ethics boards all
conducted within the last ten years and
he basically quit doing it because he
was a pretty straight scientist you know
he was measuring heart rate and pulse
and all that sort of thing trying to
look at the physiology and then the
people he was giving these chemicals to
kept coming back and telling him these
these crazy stories and well it just it
was too much for him you know and no
wonder you know because they all said
the same thing and he'd say well that
was a dream and they say no and it was
the most real thing that ever happened
to me and he'd say well you know it's an
archetypal experience and they'd say no
no no that was no archetypal experience
I went somewhere else and I saw things
and I'm back and like I don't care what
you think and like who the hell knows
right because it's all subjective but
but the weird thing about it is that
everyone's reporting the same thing how
the hell do you account
for that and then the shaman you know
when they take these psychedelic
chemicals they basically say the same
thing they say well first of all it more
or less killed me
that's this you know I dissolved two
skeleton and then I climbed the tree
that unites heaven and earth and I went
into the realm of the gods and they gave
me some information and I'm back it's
like okay well you know we don't really
know what to make of that and we and
certainly that's what Elia describes
when he describes the shamanic the
shamanic procession not the shamanic
initiation and you know there's
dissolution to a skeleton first and then
like a death the symbolic death or
experienced as an actual death and then
bang up into the realm of the gods and
then they come back it's a very old idea
and that's a medieval representation of
the tunnel that people travel through at
the end of their life to you know to
find the light which is a very common
near-death experience report and people
don't have any idea what the hell to do
with those reports except say well it's
the paroxysm zuv the dying brain which
you'd expect to be a hell of a lot more
random in my opinion and the idea is
there's a rebirth after that and you
know here this is the Scandinavian
representation of that tree that unites
earth with heaven and so there's the
Scandinavian representation it has a
snake snakes down here eating it and
then that's the Amazonian representation
it's like how the hell do you account
for that I mean those those pictures are
so similar that it's just it's beyond
belief well you know we lived in trees
for a long time a long long long long
time millions of years and there were
lots of snakes around them and so the
idea that reality is a tree that's
surrounded by a snake is that's in us
man it's down there it's deep and
there's something about it that's true
now not true like we normally think of
truth a truth true in an entirely
different manner so and all that's
pretty damn strange we'll stop with this
my son drew this when he was seven years
old blew me away man I thought it was so
cool so I had it laminated and so here
is what it is on the right hand side
that's ordered it's like the yin-yang
thing that's order left-side chaos
right and those are all mushroom houses
which I thought was amazing and then
there's this river that runs right down
the middle like the line for order and
chaos and then there's this tree that
goes up to heaven and that's heaven up
there it's like there st. Peter there's
the pearly gates there's the clouds it's
like it's he never went to church you
know it's like what the hell and then
there's a little bug there that goes up
and down from heaven to earth and that
was him and I thought he had a very
organized psyche that kid he was a very
very stable kid and still yes and I he
drew that and I thought Jesus that's
just bloody will unbelievable and I
still think that when I look at it and
that's a great example of an archetype
and so we'll see you Tuesday
[Applause]